ready to turn up the heat on some
serious comedy watch the trailer for
playing the fire coming at you no
gentlemen we are smokejumpers the most
elite team of firefighters in the world
we must be in our very back to your
parents I'm legally bound to take area
so that's what I'm gonna do an intern
you're gonna be obedient so we can do
our job and when you do this when you
when you go like like that it's not
helpful Oh soon anagen is under my watch
me by your man can't turn my neck what
needs to happen this second is you got
to watch your tone little sister or what
masher is coming to rock you work what
just happened I think the baby just
broke a dog suit Big Daddy I get
distracted I can't do this job
effectively don't you remember what it's
like to be a kid did we kill you
[Music]
[Applause]
now it's a party
what kind of firefighters are you I know
you don't see it but yes we decide
[Music]
oh what a rush
bow-bow boom-boom-boom-boom
[Music]
mm-hmm don't look at me so don't do it
or I'm gonna blow this dumb is not yet
ready
[Music]
you